[Music]
clearly kylie jenner has no issue
roasting her big sister kendall i'm
having fun it all went down on social
media over the weekend the famous fam
was in italy to celebrate kourtney
kardashian and travis barker's lavish
wedding only issue well the ceremony was
at the top of a hill and those couture
dresses weren't exactly flexible
these stairs are crazy yeah kenny's
tight gown didn't leave much room for
movement forcing her to walk bow legged
up the stairs but that wasn't the only
time kai had a little fun trolling her
big sis on tick tock she posted this
video of the two at the reception her
caption me and cucumber girl
if cucumber girl has you feeling
confused we'll give you the backstory
earlier this month kendall went viral
for her interesting cucumber cutting
technique shown on an episode of the
kardashians do you want um the chef to
make you a snack i'm making it myself
just gotta chop up some cucumber it's
pretty amazing
you go girl
be careful because i cut i nipped myself
the other day i don't know i'm kind of
scared there you go
don't cucumbers have seeds
oh yeah they're definitely
not a good cutter so don't zoom in on me
i'm not professional whatsoever it made
headlines everywhere and was all over
social media it was even discussed on
the today show i've sliced many a
cucumber in my day i don't see
a different style what was wrong with
that i don't know she was holding it
people were enraged so how did kenny
feel after catching wind of all the talk
about it she made light of the moment
sarcastically calling the whole thing
quote tragic and now seems kylie wants
her sister to embrace her new cucumber
girl nickname my taste in music is your
face
and it takes a song to come around but
of course it's all love between the two
as they spent the weekend together
celebrating their oldest sister's big
day kylie shared several peeks into the
over-the-top weekend as she made
memories with her four-year-old daughter
stormy check out the makeup mogul
looking stunning in a floral dress with
matching red lipstick while stormy rocks
a white dress and matching shoes i love
it kylie and stormi make the italian
riviera coastline their backdrop and it
seems stormy's perfected her skills
behind the camera too
that's stormy snapping away as her
famous mama poses it up on a cheetah
print lounge chair kylie captions the
post my babies got me
[Music]
you